self-discipline as i am presenting it to
you here
has referenced not only to your mastery
of negative habits which stand in the
way of your success
but more particularly
to your development and enforcement of
the positive habits you will need in
order to avail yourself of the six
assets you brought over with you in that
sealed envelope i mentioned in our first
visit
now let me give you a list of the more
important things over which you will
have to exercise self-discipline before
you can embrace and use the great master
key to riches one
you will have to gain mastery over your
tongue
by acquiring the habit of thinking first
and then speaking
after you're sure that what you say will
benefit you and not injure others
a loose tongue often is one's uh
greatest liability
two
you will have to exercise
self-discipline in mastering the common
tendency to strike back at those at whom
you have a cause real or imaginary for a
grievance
you must remember that everything you do
to or for another you do too or for
yourself
because your every thought and every act
which benefits or injures another person
comes back to you in kind
greatly multiplied
so if you feel that you must slander
another person
do not speak it but write it
write it in the sands near the water's
edge then move away from it until the
tides have flown
three
you will have to exercise
self-discipline over all of your
emotions particularly your emotions of
love hate fear and sex these are the big
four of your emotions
and they can make you or break you
according to the extent of discipline
you exercise over them
four
your mental attitude needs discipline
and control at all times
lacking this discipline
it can and it often does uh drive away
friends destroy opportunities to get
ahead
brings on physical and mental illness
develops stomach ulcers and
makes peace of mind impossible
five
i have reserved the emotion of sex for
special mention
because the failure to exercise
self-discipline over this emotion
probably heads the list of all the
causes of personal failure
the emotion of sex is the most powerful
of all emotions
and it is nature's great creative
instrument with which all species of
living things are perpetuated
the proper means of self-discipline of
the emotion of sex is transmutation the
control and direction of this great
emotional feeling toward the attainment
of worthy purposes such as the
fulfillment of one's major purpose in
life
the great leaders artists orators
industrialists and professional people
have learned the art of sex
transmutation through the proper system
of self-discipline
because of the delicacy of the subject
of sex emotion
i am limited as to the information i can
give you about it on this visit but i
have covered the subject much more in
detail in some of my books
and six
your stomach also needs discipline
through the proper habits of dieting and
fasting
because information on dieting and
fasting should come from your own doctor
i will not go into details concerning
them except to call your attention to
the need for knowledge on this subject
uh personally i attribute my sound
physical health mainly to the habits of
dieting and fasting which i have
developed through the years
and seven
you will need to exercise
self-discipline in relation to religion
and politics because our country which
is the most acceptable form of society
civilization has yet produced is made up
of people of varying beliefs in
connection with both of these subjects
to be happy and prosperous in our
country we must learn to live and to let
live to give others the privileges we
ask and demand for ourselves
and this often calls for strict
discipline over self
eight
but i have reserved until the last my
reference to the most important
circumstances over which you must
exercise the strictest of
self-discipline if you are to embrace
and use the great master key to riches i
have reference to your profound
privilege of taking possession of your
own mind
and directing it to whatever ends you
may desire you cannot take possession of
your own mind or direct it to definite
ends without a practical system
i have devoted the better portion of my
past life to the revelation and
presentation of such a system
and i know that this system works
because it has been successfully used by
many millions of people throughout the
world
the system is not only practical and
workable but it is so simple that anyone
who is ready for it
may master it and use it successfully
its use does not call for a genius nor a
great amount of formal education
it calls only for a will to take
possession of one's own mind
and a definite purpose to which the mind
is to be directed
self-disciplined by thomas a edison
made him the world's greatest inventor
who revealed to mankind during the first
half of the 20th century
more of nature secrets than had been
uncovered during the entire previous
history of civilization
self-discipline carried wilbur and
orville wright through a multitude of
failures
and enabled them finally to give the
world its first practical airplane
an achievement which has made the world
smaller and changed the entire trend of
civilization
self-discipline helped helen keller to
triumph over deafness blindness and
dumbness a combination of afflictions
such as most people never experience
self-discipline helped me to carry on
through years of heartache
discouragement and defeat
and give the world the first practical
philosophy of success
based on the know-how
gained by hundreds of men and women who
spent a lifetime by the trial and error
method
in discovery of the principles which
lead to personal success
self-discipline is among the top-ranking
features of all the great religions
including of course the christian faith
and there are some people who believe
that our major purpose on earth is that
of developing wisdom
through struggle and self-discipline
one thing is certain
no one ever becomes very wise without
the aid of self-discipline
and no one ever finds peace of mind
and happiness without the strict
exercise of self-discipline
self-discipline is the only means of
transmuting sorrow into faith
it is the only means by which we may
transmute hatred of others into the
milder emotion of sympathy for them
it is the only means by which we may
reveal and
profit by the seed of an equivalent
benefit which comes with every adversity
and every defeat
it is the only means by which we may
shut out of our minds the deadly effects
of past experiences of suffering and
unpleasantness and it is the means by
which we may discover that other self we
carry around with us that self which has
great capacity for belief
and does not become influenced by
failure and defeat
self-discipline can give us freedom from
the fear of death the most difficult to
measure of all of our fears it can free
us from the disease of hypochondria the
fear of imaginary illness with which so
many people suffer and sometimes die
self-discipline is the means by which we
may think our own thoughts live our own
lives as we wish to live them and remain
forever free from the evils of fears and
limitations which we have inherited from
the dark ages before the dawn of
civilization
the creator never gives one an asset or
benefit without passing along with it
the means by which it may be embraced
and used
self-discipline therefore is the means
by which the creator provided us with a
method of embracing and using the only
thing over which we have unchallengeable
control
the power of our own thoughts
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back a lack of belief in yourself
you watch these videos because you know
there's something more inside you too
you've got michael jordan level genius
at something so today let's live your
best believe life and learn this special
wealth formula
enjoy
rule number two develop a positive
mental attitude as i have suggested in
previous visits
a positive mental attitude can clear
away all obstacles which stand between
you and your major purpose in life
because of the importance of the subject
of our visit
i shall not only tell you that a
positive mental attitude heads the
entire list of the 12 great riches in
life
but i am going to give you explicit
instructions as to what you must do to
keep your mind positive
in all the success books i have written
i have never suggested to my readers
what they should do without clearly
telling them how to do it are you ready
if you are ready this visit may bring
the most important change in your life
you have ever experienced one
learn to adjust yourself to other
people's state of mind and difficulties
so as to get along peacefully
with them and to refrain from taking
notice of trivial circumstances in your
relations with other people by refusing
to allow them to become controversial
incidents
uh great people always avoid small
incidents of controversy when possible
two establish for yourself a definite
fixed system of conditioning your mind
at the beginning of each day so you will
keep it positive under all circumstances
three
learn the art of selling yourself to
other people by in direction such as
asking leading questions which will
bring out the sort of reactions from
others which you desire
and do not permit yourself to be drawn
into argument over unimportant subjects
four
adopt the habit of having a good hearty
laugh every time you become irritated or
angry and it will help you if you begin
each day with one minute of hardy
laughing
this will change the chemistry of your
brain and start you out with a positive
mental attitude
however you had better get out of sight
when you take your laughing exercise
five start each day with an expression
of gratitude for all the adversities
defeats failures you have experienced in
the past
and the search for the seed of an
equivalent benefit these uh have yielded
you through the passing of time then
give thanks for the blessings you expect
to receive during the day
six
learn to concentrate your attention on
the can-do portion of all of your
problems and desires and start action
where you stand in carrying out this
portion
no matter what may be your problem or
your desire there is always something
you can do right now that will help you
find out what this something is and do
it
seven
learn to transmute all unpleasant
circumstances into immediate action
which calls for a positive mental
attitude and make this a fixed habit for
example when you are angry switch your
mind to some sort of action in
connection with your hobby or your major
purpose in life and to keep it busy with
that subject for five minutes
eight
recognize that every circumstance which
influences your life whether it is a
pleasant or unpleasant circumstance is
risks for your meal of life and so use
it to make it pay you dividends in one
form or another
remembering meanwhile that your strength
grows out of your struggles
follow this instruction and you will
soon learn that there is no such thing
as an unprofitable experience
nine
look upon your life as a continuous
process of education of learning from
all your experiences good and bad and to
be always on the alert for
gains of wisdom which come to you a
little at a time in both your pleasant
and unpleasant experiences 10.
make the world over to fit your own
pattern if you choose
but uh begin with yourself in some sort
of self-improvement which will make you
more open-minded patient and generous in
your relations with others 11.
express gratitude twice daily for your
recognition of the fact that you have
been given complete control over your
own mind
and ask for guidance in order that you
may use this profound gift wisely in all
your thoughts and acts
12.
go out of your way daily to comment
enthusiastically on the good qualities
of those with whom you live and work
but do not mention their negative
qualities then observe with benefit to
yourself how quickly others will begin
to concentrate on your good qualities
remember
i'm still talking about how to keep your
mind positive
and thirteen
accept all criticism of yourself as an
occasion for self-examination to
determine how much of it is justified
and you will be sure to make startling
discoveries about yourself which will
help you to
the remainder of your life
14
do not accept from life or anyone else
anything you do not desire and remember
that mahatma gandhi proved himself to be
more powerful than the great british
military forces by this simple method of
passive resistance
15 remember always that there are two
kinds of circumstances which cause you
to worry
those you can do something about
and those you can do nothing about
nothing that is except to use passive
resistance and refuse to permit them to
worry you 16.
keep your mind eternally engaged in
thinking of that which you desire most
your major purpose in life so no time
will be left for you to waste on
thinking of that which you do not want
and let me digress here
while i tell you we are now rubbing
elbows with the great masterkey of
success this very moment and 17
if you should ever be so unfortunate as
to feel sorry for yourself
look around until you find someone who
is worse off than yourself and start
while you stand to give him help
make this procedure a habit
and you will witness one of the great
miracles of life because that which you
do to or for another
you do to or for yourself
and 18
choose some person whom you consider to
be
the sort of person you would like to be
then go to work and emulate that person
in every way possible
uh great people have always been
hero worshipers
but they picked the right sort of people
to emulate
19.
cultivate your tone of voice so that
your words have a pleasing musical sound
and remember that the sound of your
voice
is an open window through which other
people look into your very soul
it will be a profitable investment if
you will get a tape recording machine
and record samples of your voice daily
while you practice the art of expressing
yourself through a friendly sounding
voice
if you are engaged in selling this
practice will quickly pay off in
monetary dividends
20
last but by no means the least write out
this sentence and paste it in a
prominent place where you work and on a
mirror where you see yourself in your
home
whatever the mind can conceive and
believe the mind can achieve
remember also that you are the only
person who can provide you with a
positive mental attitude
what are you going to do about it
on your answer to this question rest
your entire future rule number three
think accurately the rules of accurate
thinking are so clear and simple that i
often wonder why so few people
ever take time to learn the rules since
accurate thinking is the very foundation
of all successful achievements
in this visit i shall give you a working
description of the rules of accurate
thinking which all successful people
follow
first of all accurate thinking is based
on two simple fundamentals they are
called inductive reasoning and deductive
reasoning inductive reasoning is used
when the necessary facts on which to
base your thinking are not available in
this case you act on hypotheses or what
you assume the facts to be
deductive reasoning is used when you
have the facts or what appear to be the
facts on which to base your thinking the
next step in accurate thinking is to
separate facts from fiction or hearsay
evidence and determine whether you are
dealing with hypotheses or real facts
when you are sure you have dependable
facts on which to base your thinking you
take the second step by separating these
facts into two classes one is important
facts and the other is unimportant facts
when you do this you may be surprised at
the overwhelmingly greater number of
unimportant facts you deal with daily
than there are important facts at this
point you are almost sure to want to ask
the question
what is an important fact
and how can i distinguish it from an
unimportant fact
and i shall give you the answer to this
very important question by saying
that an important fact is any fact which
will aid you to any extent whatsoever in
attaining the object of your major
purpose in life and all other facts as
far as you are concerned are unimportant
and you should waste no time with them
after this visit is over you can employ
the next hour to a great benefit to
yourself if you will set down on paper a
list of all the facts you deal with
yesterday
separating them into two classes
important and unimportant as a matter of
fact you will make a profound discovery
regarding accurate thinking if you
follow the habit of daily taking
inventory of all the facts that claims
your attention during the day putting
them down on paper in two separate
columns one labeled important facts and
the other labeled unimportant facts
now let us turn our attention to the
subject of opinions
and see to what extent loose unsound
opinions are mistaken for accurate
thinking to start with let us recognize
the truth that most opinions are without
value because they are based on bias
prejudice intolerance guesswork hearsay
evidence and out and out ignorance uh
these are harsh words i'm using and they
represent the source of most of the
tragedies of life which people meet with
unnecessarily and i would say that of
all the tragedies which cause misery and
failure none is more merciless or
destructive than those which grow out of
the indifference of people who make no
attempt to learn how to think accurately
i shall never forget an experience i had
with president woodrow wilson while i
was working for him during world war one
i asked the president what effect he
believed world war one would have on
civilization
and his reply was brief but it was a
masterpiece which you should remember as
long as you live
i cannot answer your question said the
president
because i have no facts on which to base
an opinion if you will remember woodrow
wilson's 15 word speech every time you
are about to express an opinion about
anything
the chances are that you will soon get
out of the habit of expressing or even
having opinions not based on something
more substantial and biases prejudices
and emotional feelings which often serve
as fathers to facts
you will learn if you observe carefully
that the more successful a person is the
less he is inclined to express wild
unjustified opinions about anything also
you must have observed already that the
drifters who are suffering with
frustrations because they recognize they
are failures usually have an assortment
of opinions on about everything you can
imagine when i hear someone expressing a
definite opinion about something of
which i have definite reason to believe
he knows little or nothing i think of an
experience i had when i stopped the
quaker on the streets of philadelphia
and asked him the time of day
he took out his watch examined it
carefully and then in a slow emphatic
tone of voice he said
well sir
according to this alleged timepiece
it appears to be approximately one
minute and ten seconds past twelve
o'clock
i was particularly impressed by the care
with which this quaker identified the
source of his information which he was
passing on to me
and i often thought effort how
beneficial it would be if all people who
express opinions or give out information
would take the time to identify the
source from which they were able to
speak
i cannot influence all people to engage
in this sort of safe thinking but i can
suggest that you give it consideration
in connection with this visit on the
subject of accurate thinking
now i shall give you a simple rule which
may help you avoid being misled by
unsound opinions expressed by other
people when you hear someone make a
statement which your reason cannot
accept as being sound or which you
question or should for safety say
question for any reason whatsoever
ask a simple forward question
how do you
know
then stand firm on that question and
either force the speaker to identify the
source from which he got the information
he is endeavoring to pass on as facts or
reject the statement entirely as if it
had not been made
and do this no matter who is speaking or
what may be his reputation for truth and
veracity
remember you were given as your richest
birthright the privilege of controlling
your own thoughts
therefore treat this divine gift with
the profound respect which it is
entitled and do not allow anyone to do
your thinking for you or to influence
your thinking in any manner whatsoever
except by the rules of accurate thinking
i am passing on to you
follow this procedure regardless of what
people think or say about your method of
thinking if they wish to call you a
cynic or a doubting thomas let that be
their misfortune
but for your own good go right on
thinking by rules which will save you
from many mistakes and tragedies
throughout your life
now i will give you seven rules to
follow which if you memorize them and
follow them as a daily habit may bring
you top rating as an accurate thinker
one never accept the opinions of other
people as being facts until you have
learned the source of those opinions and
satisfied yourself of their accuracy two
remember that free advice no matter from
whom it is received will bear the
closest of examination before it is
acted upon as safe and generally
speaking this sort of advice is worth
exactly what it costs
three alert yourself immediately when
you hear anyone speaking of others in a
discourteous or slanderous spirit
because this very fact should put you on
notice that what you are hearing is
biased to say the very least about it
and it may be out and out misstatement
for in asking others for information do
not disclose to them what you wish the
information to be
because most people have the bad habit
of trying to please under such
circumstances
well-measured tactful questions can be
of great benefit to you in thinking
accurately
five
remember that anything which exists
anywhere throughout the universe is
capable of proof and where no such proof
is available it is safer to assume
nothing exists
six one of the great unexplainable
miracles consists in the fact that both
truth and falsehood no matter by what
means they may be expressed carry with
them a silent
invisible means of identifying
themselves as such
therefore
remember this truth and begin developing
the necessary intuitive faculty to
enable you to sense what is false and
what is true
seven
follow the habit of asking
how do you know when anyone makes a
statement you cannot identify as true
follow this habit faithfully and you
will see many persons squirm and turn
red in the face when you insist upon a
direct reply
the most accurate thinkers are the
scientists they investigate with open
minds and never allow their wishes to
become the fathers of facts
but deal with each fact as it is not as
they would like it to be
now one final word of warning i feel i
should leave with you
study yourself carefully and you may
discover that your own emotions are your
greatest handicap in the business of
accurate thinking
it is easy for you to believe that which
you wish to believe and unfortunately
that is precisely what most people do
this is a method by which many people
condemn themselves to eternal failure
and defeat
and it is a method which opens wide that
sealed envelope which contains the list
of penalties they must pay for
neglecting to take possession of their
minds and use them for constructive and
beneficial to themselves rule number
four have faith i say this is your
greatest asset because it is the fourth
of the 17 success principles with which
you may tap and draw upon the supreme
power which created you and runs this
entire universe
the name of this principle is applied
faith
and i want you to remember it is not
something i am bringing to you but it is
something you already possess although
you may not have made use of it in the
past
and now let me tell you what applied
faith is and what you can do with it
applied faith is the mental attitude
wherein you may clear your mind of all
fears and doubts and direct it to the
attainment of whatever you desire in
life in our first visit
i told you that you and i and every
person were blessed with the privilege
of complete control over but one thing
and that is the exclusive right to take
possession of our own minds and direct
them to the attainment of whatever we
desire in life
applied faith is a mental attitude we
must cultivate and maintain before we
can take complete possession of our
minds
it is the means by which we may break
the seal of that envelope i mentioned in
our first visit and take full possession
of the six forms of riches we get in
return for taking possession of our
minds and using them those six riches
were as you may remember
sound health
peace of mind
a labor of love of your own choice
freedom from fear and worry
a positive mental attitude and material
riches of your own choice and quantity
we are now this very moment
standing in front of the gateway which
can be opened only with the great master
key to success and i'm giving you the
closest clue i have yet mentioned
as to how you may take possession of
this key
in order that you may condition your
mind to embrace and use applied faith
you must understand that there are two
ways in which you can use faith
you can put it into reverse gear and use
it in a negative way by allowing your
mind to dwell upon the circumstances and
the things you do not want such as
poverty ill health failure defeat
and this is precisely what the majority
of people do which explains why the
majority of people go through life in
misery and walk
or
you can take possession of your mind and
direct it to think of the six riches
which came over with you in that sealed
envelope
and you will attract these riches to
bless and serve you all through your
life
isn't this a strange fact that most
people make a negative application of
their great power of faith by thinking
about and believing in poverty ill help
fear failure and defeat when it would be
so easy for them just to change their
thinking over to the circumstances and
things they desire
now let me give you a description of the
one thing which represents the main
difference between a successful person
and the faith please listen carefully
and think for yourself as i speak
because failure to recognize the truth i
am about to give you is the starting
point of most favors successful people
in all occupations all professions and
all callings have one trait which
distinguishes them from the failures
it is their capacity for belief
that failures see the hole in the donut
but do not see the donut around the hole
the successes see the hole also but they
see the doughnut around the hole
thomas a edison believed that he could
perfect an incandescent electric lamp
and despite the fact that he failed over
ten thousand times before he was crowned
with success
he made his belief uncover the secret
for which he was searching
give one guess as to how many times the
average person must fail before he quits
fails because of the lack of capacity
for belief
how many times can you meet with defeat
before you give up the ghost and quit
henry ford believed he could build a
self-propelled vehicle which would take
the place of the horse and buggy
and despite the ridicule of relatives
and neighbors and the lack of finances
he transmitted his belief into an
industrial empire which changed the
entire american way of life
mind you ford did this with very little
education and no operating capital to
begin with
you perhaps have an idea or a plan which
would be useful to other people but you
have done nothing about it because you
lack the self-confidence to give you a
start
in other words you are now where henry
ford was before he built the first model
of his world-famous automobile
uh mr ford uh broke through that wall of
fear which may not be holding you back
belief is truly a magic word
because it is the beginning of all
successes it is the very foundation of
civilization it is the one quality you
must develop before you can make use of
the great master key to success
to be successful you must become a
person with a great capacity for belief
and the place to start believing is with
yourself
you should begin by recognizing that you
were born with the privilege of complete
control over your own mind
you should also recognize
that by the application of the master
key to success
which i am passing on to you through
these visits
you can take full possession of your
mind and
make it yield you whatever you demand in
life
observe i use the word demand not big
the creator never intended for you to
beg for anything
if he had he would not have blessed you
with full control over your own mind
if your life is not what you want it to
be
you can change it
as a matter of fact you can do anything
within reason
that you desire to do if you embrace the
principle of applied faith and keep it
directed to the attainment of the things
you want and off the things you do not
want
i should know what i'm talking about
because
i was handicapped at birth by the four
horsemen
which keep most people in bondage all
the days of their lives poverty
fear
illiteracy and superstition
i have discovered the master key which
gives one deliverance from all the evils
one does not want
and opens wide the gateway to the riches
which the creator intended every person
to enjoy on this earth
applied faith is the only means by which
the master key can be appropriated and
used therefore i give you these
instructions through which you may
create a mental attitude which is
favorable for the expression of faith
one
know what you want and believe
that you can and will get it two
give expressions of gratitude many times
daily for having received that which you
want
even before you actually get physical
possession of it
possession starts first in the mind
please remember this
third
keep your mind open for hunches from
within
and when you are inspired to action do
not wait but move on your own personal
initiative at once
remember
there can be no application of applied
faith without action
fourth
when overtaken by defeat as you may be
many times
remember that man's faith is tested many
times before he is crowned with final
victory
and accept your defeat as nothing more
than a challenge to keep on trying
and five
a burning desire for the things or
circumstances you want is the starting
point of all applied faith
be definite
believe
and act
and keep on acting if at first you meet
with a defeat
six
when doubt creeps into your mind
remember that uh
whatsoever a man believeth that shall he
also reap
remember
faith is not something you get
faith is something you already have but
you may be using it in reverse gear by
believing in the circumstances
and things you do not want the things
you fear
remember also
that faith is guidance only it is not a
power which will bring you what you want
but a power that can guide you to go
after what you want and get it
remember too that your faith is limited
only by your own capacity to believe
you can do whatever you make up your
mind to do
i believed i could give the world a
practical philosophy of success which
would free men and women from their
fears and limitations
i stood firmly back of that bleed
through 20 odd years of effort
and to saw my belief give freedom to
millions of people
do the things said emerson and you shall
have the power
may i paraphrase this great truth by
saying
believe
and you shall receive
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there rule number five learn from
adversity yes the principle of learning
from adversity makes it possible for you
to transmute all your past failures and
mistakes
into an asset which will help you
achieve outstanding success in the
future
at the very outset of this visit i wish
to call your attention to an important
fact which may give you immediate
possession of the great master key to
success
namely
that your positive mental attitude is
the only means by which you may convert
adversities defeats and failures into
assets
it seems to have been intended that
everyone should experience adversities
defeats and even failures as a part of
nature's method of disciplining people
to learn how to take possession of their
own minds
but the creator very wisely provided
everyone with the means for converting
these experiences into benefits of a
priceless value
the means being our privilege of
maintaining and directing a positive
mental attitude
despite the benefits which we may get
from adversities and unpleasant
experiences of every nature no one
desires to meet with these experiences
a failure or defeat is just as
unpleasant to me now as it was 30 odd
years ago when i was learning about
failures and unpleasant experiences in
the great university of hart knox
yet
i would be something less than fair with
you
if i neglected to tell you that my
greatest blessings came from my greatest
adversities
but these blessings never would have
been
recognized by me if i had not learned
the truth that every adversity carries
with it the seed of an equivalent
benefit which is the very hub of this
visit with you
once you learn that adversities can be
made to pay dividends you will acquire
the habit of looking for that seed of an
equivalent benefit in each such
experience with which you meet
come with me now and i shall give you
some examples which prove conclusively
that failures defeats unpleasant
experiences can be converted into
stepping stones on which one may rise to
great heights of personal achievement
my first illustration concerns the man
of whom you may have heard
and i have no doubt you have eaten some
of the food which he produced and
marketed throughout the nation
as a result of an adversity which would
have stopped most men cold
the man was milo c jones who owned a
small farm near fort atkinson wisconsin
on which he made only a fair living
until he was stricken down with double
paralysis which deprived him of every
portion of his body except his brain
in this hour of his greatest adversity
milose jones used his mind
took possession of it for the first time
in his life perhaps
and out of that mind came the idea of
raising hogs and converting them into
little pig sausage
and on that same farm where previous to
that adversity he made only a mere
living
he found the seed of an equivalent
benefit that compensated him for the
loss of the use of his body
and lived to see little pig sausage
yield him a huge fortune
isn't it strange that so often people
have to be cut down by failure and
defeat
before they learn that they have minds
capable of mastering all of their
problems
isn't it strange why milo c jones did
not discover the little pig sausage idea
while he had a sound body
my next illustration is based on an
adversity of a man whom we all know
because he was president of the united
states and his name was franklin d
roosevelt
who was stricken in the prime of his
life with polio which destroyed the use
of his legs
instead of sitting on a street corner
with a tin cup and some lead pencils as
many another might have done
under similar circumstances
franklin d roosevelt transmuted his
affliction into a buildup of his
self-reliance and lifted himself to the
highest position available to mankind
anywhere on this earth
got that position and held it until he
passed on
held it longer than had any previous
president
verily i tell you with all the
enthusiasm at my command
that you may find in your adversities
the necessary challenge to inspire you
on to success such as you never would
have known without these experiences
i do not suggest that you look for
adversities
or expect to meet with them but if you
do so just remember not to fear them
and instead of brooding over them as
most people do let me suggest that you
be different
and convert them into stepping stones on
which you may rise to whatever place in
life you have set for yourself
three
my next illustration is based on you and
all the adversities and failures you
have ever experienced
i shall not go into details because i do
not know the details of any such
experiences you may have met with but
this much i do know
i have brought to you in this visit the
means by which you can convert all your
past disappointments and all of your
future adversities and failures into a
seed of equivalent benefit
you can do this by the simple process of
appropriating and putting to your use
the nine
success principles i have given you
previously
if you do not remember these nine
principles write to me and i will tell
you how to get copies of them
right here may i remind you of the great
importance of following the principle of
a positive mental attitude
because this is the principle you will
need most in converting unpleasant
experiences into assets
four
my next illustration involves a very
intimate personal experience of my own
which began when my mother passed on
i was eight years of age
i know that the loss of one's mother at
any age usually is regarded as an
irreparable loss which offers no
possible benefits
but even in the laws of loved ones we
may find that there is a seed of an
equivalent benefit
i found that seed in one of the most
wonderful persons i have ever known
when my father brought home my new
mother
it was she who inspired me to prepare
myself for the opportunity i was to
receive later in life
when i met andrew carnegie and received
from him the commission to organize the
world's first practical philosophy of
personal success
had it not been for the loss of my
mother i would not now be having this
visit with you
and my books would not now be serving to
help millions of people throughout the
world to find their places in life
just remember this about adversities
nothing is ever so bad or so unpleasant
that it may not yield some benefit if we
keep a positive mental attitude toward
the experience and make it a habit to
look for that seed of an equivalent
benefit
this of course involves the application
of that important success principle
personal initiative
five
now i come to an illustration which
involves our great american way of life
and all the personal freedom and
opportunities we enjoy under our way of
life and it begins with our defeat of
the british in 1778
probably every britisher believed that
the loss of the american colonists was
an irreparable loss which offered no
possible benefits yet you and i know
that if we had not defeated the british
and made ourselves rich and powerful
the british empire probably would have
been wiped out in world wars 1 or 2.
we know also that although the british
empire survived those two wars it was
our financial help which saved the
british from starvation and bankruptcy
so
today every britisher should give thanks
for the defeat of lord cornwallis's
armistice because that defeat finally
became the means of survival of the
british empire
six
my next illustration
brings us face to face with an adversity
which involves you and i and every other
person now living
an adversity from which we have not yet
availed ourselves of that seed of an
equivalent benefit which is to be found
in all adversities
i have referenced to the trend in this
and all other countries
to rob individuals of their rights of
personal freedom
a trend which is in direct violation of
the obvious purpose of the creator to
give every individual the privilege of
freedom of thought and action
there is something definite you and i
can do about this common trend to rob us
of our rights of personal freedom
we cannot turn it back entirely by our
individual efforts
but we can and we should do something
about it where it affects us
individually and where we know what we
can do and how we can do it
of course you will ask
what can i do to influence a world trend
and i shall answer by saying there is
something definite that you can do
you can refuse to accept this common
trend and take full possession of your
own mind thus fulfilling your personal
responsibility to your creator
remember those two sealed envelopes i
mentioned in a previous visit
one of them is labeled riches you may
enjoy by taking possession of your own
mind
very well you have a responsibility to
yourself
your loved ones your creator
to take possession of your own mind and
to direct it to ends of your own choice
this responsibility is yours and no one
else can rob you of it or fulfill it for
you
you also have a responsibility to your
country
which has given you our great american
way of life
our great system of free enterprise
which is so designed as to provide one
with every possible motive for taking
possession of his own mind and writing
his own ticket in life
we should remember that our benefits
under the american way of life like
every other blessing we have been given
at birth
is something we can retain and enjoy
only by making the fullest and best use
of it
it is definitely a part of the overall
plan of the universe to give man the
benefit only of those blessings he
recognizes embraces and uses
constructively
tie your arm to your side and take it
out of use and nature rebels immediately
by causing the arm to atrophy
wither and become useless neglect to
keep in contact with your friends and to
cultivate them and you lose them
show indifference to the patrons from
whom you earn your living or the
employer who pays your wages
and very soon you find yourself without
a market for your services
it is an inevitable law of nature that
you lose that which you do not use and
of course this applies to the use of
your own mind the same as to everything
else
and we who so often boast that we are
citizens of the richest the greatest and
the most powerful nation civilization
has yet produced will do well to
remember this law
through which we lose that which we do
not properly use rule number six master
the rules of investing i always borrow
to invest
one of my favorite books that just came
out with us called fake fake money fake
teachers fake assets
i use debt to invest but to be able to
do that to go to here to get rich to do
that you've really got to have a lot of
financial education i don't recommend it
but it's the best way to get rich
president trump
you know my friend we wrote two books
together i know some of you guys hate
him a lot of people hate the guy but
he's very smart he's a capitalist obama
socialist communist
hillary
crook so anyway
be very careful right now because i use
debt trump uses debt the more debt we
use the less tax we pay that is why i
love real estate
i can use debt
and pay no taxes make a lot of money so
that's really what i teach i don't
recommend it
but for those of you who understand
what's called an infinite return
it's the best way to get rich but you
have to have a lot of financial
education
so the reason the rich don't pay taxes
is because there's three types of income
they'll never teach you this in school
the fake teachers
number one type of three types of income
okay number one type of income is earned
income
that's earned income
it's when you work for money
it's earned
so that earned income
shows up here
so these are the guys that pay tax so
when all the guys are screaming taxed
are rich
well you can't tax them because they
don't have jobs
it's kind of funny isn't it we're going
to tax the rich oh yeah good luck you
know
the second type of income
is portfolio income and portfolio income
is from flipping houses or you buy a
stock for like ten dollars you sell it
for twenty dollars
that's portfolio income
okay i don't do that trump doesn't do
that
so most guys who are flipping houses and
all that buying stocks and flipping to
foot two
you're getting this type of income so
this
this income is about 20 percent today
some of that here
but the income that the rich work for
is called
passive income
passive income is also known as
cash flow
that's the name of our game
cash flow
and that income is income
that's flowing from here to here
it bypasses taxes
so i know this doesn't sound fair and it
isn't fair i don't disagree with you but
what's not fair is our schools which are
part of the problem
we'll never explain that our school
system is so fake
it's more fake than those fake plastic
plants
and these teachers bless their heart
they don't know any of this
and i really want to talk to you about
the most important subject for all of us
today rich young poor old it's called
financial education
and as you know our school systems teach
us nothing about money nothing it's
pathetic
you know they have financial literacy
courses today well that's not financial
education you know it's really pathetic
and what's happening for most people
today
is you know they follow that age-old
mantra go to school
what to learn about money at school
nothing
get a job
while jobs are disappearing not only
that
is that with artificial intelligence and
g5 coming more jobs are going to be
wiped out plus with driverless cars more
jobs are getting wiped out
so why would you go to school to get a
job
and then work hard for money but and pay
taxes taxes are going to keep going up
sports fans they have to somebody's
going to pay off this massive
mountain of debt stacking up all over
the world
and the only way they pay off debt is
via taxes
and then they tell you to get out of
debt oh god
debt is money please understand me in
1971 when nixon took the dollar off the
gold standard
money became debt
so the rich know how to use debt
to get rich
and that's what i do
my friend donald trump i know so you
hate the guy more power to you you know
but we use debt as money and other guys
will tell you get out of debt
well
you choose
the rich use debt to get rich and the
poor middle class get wiped out because
they're in debt
that's because of the lack of financial
education and they tell you invest for
the long term on a well-diversified
portfolio of stocks buyers mutual funds
and etfs
the key word in there is invest for the
long term
why would you invest for the long term
when they're printing trillions of
dollars and zerp zero interest rate
policy they're paying you nothing for
your money
and you're gonna hold for the long term
and you've got hft high frequency
trading
you know that they could they can trade
a thousand pieces of stock in a second
and you don't have a prayer you're
you're trading against a machine
a robot
so all this financial advice people are
giving out there
is a recipe for disasters
again this is my message to
anybody including millennials
is where is your head
you know i know most most millennials
they want a high paying job
they want to be able to pay the rent and
eat and all this stuff
and then you dream of the big house a
nice car and all that
but that's why
99 of americans are broke because their
heads are on the wrong spot so when i
asked kim if she would take an
accounting course was just two days
you know
i wanted to see if your head
could get into the asset column
that was the difference wasn't it yeah
and actually it didn't happen right at
that moment but it's you fell in love
with me
of course i did of course i did
but this started this started the
journey on
investing the start of the the journey
on assets
but i do remember the moment down the
road where just like everybody else i
was focused on the income column get a
job get the pay raises if you're an
hourly rate wage work more hours or
raise your hourly wage so i was always
focused here and then finally is after
we'd actually bought some investment
properties the light finally went on and
unlike instead of focusing on acquiring
income
what if we focus on just acquiring
assets
that the assets go into the income
so that was a huge shift in my mindset
and once that shift happened for me i
don't think about the income column
anymore i just think about the acid
column and that's and that's our game
called cash flow the first way you
understand risk is you look in the
mirror
it's who's looking back at you
you're the risk
not
the investment for example
i invest in a lot of real estate
and say oh
real estate is so risky so i think i'll
buy etfs
so you play it safe but but you'll learn
more by investing in real estate right
because you'll make more mistakes yeah
so that's the difference there so it's
not real estate that's risky it's your
risk yeah and and sometimes it's ironic
because i think about it like
so blindly turning your money away to
someone you barely know isn't risky or
let's say i don't know maybe just
depending on this job where your
employer can fire you any day isn't
risky either you know it just it makes
you think a little what truly is risky
for you yeah how do you define it and
you look at all the pensions of the
school teachers firefighters all guys
with 401ks they're all bankrupt because
wall street stole their money from them
you know
in the federal reserve bank
they're run by phds like my poor head
and ph.d stands for poor helpless and
desperate the fed has not been right in
years everybody worships the federal
reserve bank the other day somebody says
what do you think about artificial
intelligence i said oh are you talking
about the federal reserve bank
you know
they're they're a criminal operation
they're the guy stealing from our
pension systems this
it's horrible what's going on because we
have all these phds poor helpless and
desperate people
who are risk averse
it's funny isn't it it's really funny
but let me tell you what risk is so yeah
okay perfect
so when you go to your banker
your banker does not ask you for your
report card
so here's the cash flow game and this is
called the financial statement what
makes the cash flow game different from
monopoly which my how my rich dad taught
me via monopoly
is my rich had also taught me about
financial statements so the cash flow is
the only game with a financial statement
so really simply when you look at a
financial statement
there's income
expense
assets
liabilities
there's one more thing in the cash flow
game on the financial statement you'll
see
it's the most important statement of all
is called the statement of cash flow
it's off to the side here so
if you're going to be an entrepreneur or
a capitalist
you have to have one of these
you're going to be rich you have to have
one of these but 99 of all high school
students leaving school and college have
no idea what this is you have fico
scores
you know but you don't know what this is
no
so when a banker asks you
for your financial statement
they want to see how smart you are here
so let me tell you why school
makes
students poor
so really simply is this
let's say i have a master's in
[Music]
arts
master of arts degree right yeah or a
bachelor of arts degree yeah
do i learn anything about income no
what about greek mythology oh there you
go that's very important about income
and we wonder why kids are leaving
school or a young generation
looking for that high paying job what
now let me ask you this if you have a um
a degree in technology
do you learn anything about assets
never
so you could be a techie and you know
nothing about this
you could be a techie and know nothing
about this
you see when a banker looks at your
financial statement they're looking at
the mirror of you
this is a reflection of you
and if you got jack here and jack here
then you're not that smart financially
so the reason the cash flow game is such
an important game it teaches you what is
important to your banker or for a
capitalist or for an entrepreneur is
that entrepreneurs got to know how to
increase their income yeah
and
an entrepreneur has got to know how to
create assets
if you don't know those two things you
should not be an entrepreneur
you should be an employee
which is why so many young people coming
out of school
have massive student loan debt over here
right
but they don't know anything about this
and about this year
that's risky
and we always have to find outside
outside resources to like find this
information learn this information you
know taking courses here at rich dad
learning through your seminars and so
it's really astonishing how
something that's supposed to prepare you
for the future leaves you with just
the most important documents that we're
told that we need to have our resume and
your report cards your transcripts but
in reality you're gonna be an employee
exactly
but for entrepreneurship which is what a
lot of people come to us for
this is where you can learn it here
because in the school system you won't
you see if you're going to increase your
income right over here
you need a real teacher
if you're going to acquire assets you
need real teachers
what is high risk
is asking people who are fake teachers
like my calculus teacher
and my
accounting accounting you love
accounting teachers don't you no i hate
them did your accounting teacher know
anything about this no nothing did your
account teach you nothing about this no
that's risky
so that's why i wrote the book fake fake
money fake teachers fake assets
and what wall street is tr telling you
to do was just give your money to them
yeah
that's risky so the reason i say only
lazy people
use their own money is because it takes
much more intelligence to raise capital
and so i've never been able ever since
my rich dad as a little boy my rich dad
forbade me from ever saying i can't
afford it
he says figure out how you can afford it
how can you do something figure out how
you can do something
so over my lifetime most of the projects
i i've started i've i've never had any
money i like not having money because it
forces me to think i get creative i have
to educate myself i have to talk to rich
guys
how did you do this how did you do that
how you do that and what has happened to
me and i just turned 72 i've never
needed money
because if i need money
i figure out how to raise it rule number
seven work to learn it was really hard
because i didn't like
i'm actually a very shy person
so learning how to sell was the hardest
thing i could do yeah but if i hadn't
spent four years learning how to sell i
never made it here i never made it here
so the entire time that you were here
you were preparing to jump to the other
correct
so every job is not so much for the
high-paying job with job security
for not not everybody you know most
people should have job security because
they're not designed to be entrepreneurs
but if you're going to be an
entrepreneur then you better take this
job and say well which way am i going to
go yeah
so i knew
my job at xerox
was to go here and here and here yeah
not stay here
and i actually make so much money over
here that i don't need job security
money
so really that's a lesson when you look
at a job you look at what can i learn
more than how much can i make
and i think that's the biggest challenge
and if you look for a job where you can
learn a lot
the harder the job
the better it is rule number eight learn
how to read a financial statement this
is called a financial statement what
makes the cash flow game different from
monopoly which my how my rich dad taught
me fair monopoly
is my richard also taught me about
financial statements so cash flow is the
only game with a financial statement so
really simply when you look at a
financial statement
there's income
expense
assets
liabilities
there's one more thing in the cash flow
game on the financial statement you'll
see
it's the most important statement of all
is called the statement of cash flow
it's off to the side here so
if you're going to be an entrepreneur or
a capitalist
you have to have one of these
you're going to be rich you have to have
one of these but 99 of all high school
students live in school and college have
no idea what this is you have fico
scores
you know but you don't know what this is
no
so when a banker asks you
for your financial statement they want
to see how smart you are here so let me
tell you why school
makes
students poor
so really simply is this
let's say i have a master's in
arts
master of arts degree right yeah or a
bachelor of arts degree yeah
do i learn anything about income
no what about great mythology oh there
you go that's very important about
income and wonder why kids are leaving
school or young generation
looking for that high paying job but
now let me ask you this if you have a um
a degree in technology
do you learn anything about assets
never
so you could be a techie and you know
nothing about this
you could be a techie and know nothing
about this
you see when a banker looks at your
financial statement they're looking at
the mirror of you
this is a reflection of you
and if you got jack here and jack here
then you're not that smart financially
so the reason the cash flow game is such
an important game it teaches you what is
important to your banker or for a
capitalist or for an entrepreneur is
that entrepreneurs got to know how to
increase their income yeah
and
an entrepreneur has got to know how to
create assets
if you don't know those two things you
should not be an entrepreneur
you should be an employee rule number
nine take risks millennials are the most
highly immunized the most highly
educated
generation in history they have the cell
phone they didn't get educated in school
they got educated on social media
on their cell phones
they know all the answers but they're
afraid of doing anything yeah you know
the biggest complaint about my
generation is millennials know all the
answers but they can't do anything
and the reason they can't do anything is
because you might hurt their somebody's
feelings you might make a mistake
you know this keeps you guys just
trapped in this little box here yeah
so that's one of the reasons i think
millennial money is such an important
point here because if you're going to
come into my world old guys world or
the information age you've really got to
understand what is risky and what is not
risky and in my world if you play it
safe
that makes you stupid
because if you don't take risks you
don't get smarter yeah
you know so you may know the answer but
you can't do anything yeah
and one of the best things i had is i
went from mel
i went to military school that went to
flight school
i had such great teachers you know
all of them could fly you know so my
flight instructor could fly what a novel
idea
you know a flight instructor can fly
but when i was in high school
most of my teachers were
terrified
they're all cowards you know job
security don't make mistakes just
memorize the right answer and you'll be
safe
and that's why most school teachers
aren't rich yeah and they teach that to
your generation yeah and rule number 10
the last challenge for some very special
bonus clips is learn how to raise
capital i'll share some of the insights
i've learned over the years on raising
capital again it's the most important
skill i have and just to reiterate was
in 19 approximately 1975 i came out with
this product and were extremely
successful but we kept running out of
money
the bit the more successful we got the
more we ran out of money so that's when
i went to my rich dad i tried to borrow
a hundred thousand dollars and he chewed
me out
he says why would i invest in a dumb
product when you have a bad business
and so that's what that's when he began
teaching me the next level of my
entrepreneurial education
it's not about the product it's about
how to design a business that doesn't
need me to keep raising the capital in
other words how do you design a business
that keeps raising money automatically
and today the rich dad company is cash
rich cash keeps pouring in because the
ability to raise money constantly was
designed into the business and once
again this is the diagram
this is the bi triangle these are the
eight pieces that make up a business
when a business is hurting oftentimes
it's because one of these eight pieces
is missing for example many times people
have a great product but their legal is
really bad or their communication
systems are bad
or their audit you know their internal
order processing is a bad or the
manufacturing is bad or the marketing is
bad and they or they have bad cash flow
management so part of the three day will
be discussing going into depth how you
put a solid business structure together
because this is it there's trillions
well trillions but billions of dollars
out there looking for a home
but they don't invest in products and
that was my rich dad's lesson
sophisticated investors invest in a
well-designed business so with that i'll
go into
a little more on what we'll be covering
on our three day
and some of you who are familiar with my
work understand this
when you look
at a financial statement let's say this
is
this is income
expense
asset liability okay
and as i explained in rich dad poor dad
your house is not an asset so basically
is
most people have a house they think as
an asset but every month is costing them
money through a thing called a mortgage
payment
that's
why they're broke so what makes a person
rich like what makes me rich
is very simply i have
assets such as businesses i have the
rich dad business every month
lots of money comes in i also have real
estate
i also have stocks and bonds and i have
commodities
such as i am a partner in oil companies
and every month
the cash flows into me so this is the
model
of a rich
person
whether i work or not money comes in
okay and that's what makes me rich most
people all they have is a mortgage
payment
car payment uh college loan payments and
all that that's a poor person okay
so what makes the same thing that makes
a rich person rich
and what makes a well-designed business
rich
is that as a sophisticated investor
let's say this is a rich
business
when i wrote the business plan for rich
dad poor dad this this company now
is that i had to design in assets
so one of the biggest like one of the
biggest assets which that has
is we are a brand and we license our
name
so all over the world there's about 60
people who every month send me money it
was designed into the business plan for
example
with rich dad poor dad every month
people like in japan and china and asia
and europe every month they send me
money the second thing is every time i
write a book
every month money comes in
when i design my board game every month
money comes in
and whatever what else we have
when we have seminars more money comes
in
so
every month
the business of rich dad gets richer and
richer because we're constantly setting
up more assets so what makes a person
rich is the same thing that makes a
business rich so when i designed the
rich dad company i designed it to be a
rich company once i designed this it was
very easy to raise capital capital
poured in because sophisticated
investors people on the b and i side of
the quadrant
saw that i knew how to build a rich
stable company so today the rich dad
company has
zero debt
and just tons of cash flow coming in
regardless if i work or not
so
i hope that makes sense to you is every
month or every year the rich dad company
is working to more add more assets to
the business so in this economic
downfall
downturn
money still comes in
when i designed
my velcro company i designed a wallet
and it was sold once it was sold
there was no more income coming in
it was a poorly designed business and
that's why my rich dad didn't want to
invest in my wallet company but the rich
dad company because the rich dad company
is building assets all the time it gets
to be richer and richer and richer
so
in final statement
so
so and final
i'd like to point out
so finally
[Applause]
i like to point out one more thing that
makes a company rich or poor as
business design
the reason it's hard for most people to
raise capital
i don't care if it's real estate or what
is very simply because
most people operate here
there is no asset the only asset is the
entrepreneur who's working hard like if
i own the pizza shop i have to be there
24 7 or responsible for it there's no
sense investing in it there's no sense
investing it
the other thing too if you have a
service business like remember arthur
anderson was a huge accounting firm
the moment they had a
ran into a problems with enron scandal
the whole business folded the reason
arthur anderson went down was because
they were a service building business
they were a big business but they had
tons of accountants working for them
and so the problem with a business like
arthur anderson is their assets went
home every night they had no real asset
so once again
people go home the rich dad company gets
stronger because we really do have
assets people can come and go but the
business has assets and the thing keeps
running
the final thing is this
it's the same thing ken mcelroy the
abc's of real estate my partner in real
estate deals
his business is exactly the same
so the key to raising money this is ken
mcelroy's company it's called mc
companies
ken mcelroy's business
is in the business of acquiring assets
that's why his company gets richer and
richer and richer every year he adds
probably a thousand new apartment units
to his inventory so ken's company gets
richer and richer because mc cor company
is designed to increase assets
poorly designed businesses never have
any assets they have huge
liabilities i trust that makes sense to
you so can mcelroy's business get
stronger and stronger and stronger
because every year she's increasing more
assets the rich dad company gets
stronger and stronger and stronger
because every year we add more assets
this year we're adding franchising to
our mix we're also you know rich brother
red sister the book has come out we come
out the real book of real estate etc etc
and every one of those products every
year continues to send
money into our product so that's an idea
of a well-designed business
if you have a well-designed business i
don't care it's for real estate or
making
you know cash flow board games if it's
well designed investors will put give
money to you because this is a
well-designed business
most people grew up with an unhealthy
view of money some people think that
money is everything that the next person
you see the next customer you talk to
that's your next suit that's your next
car and other people think that money is
the root of all
right or the love of money is the root
of all
evil right to make money you're evil
you're slimy you're gross you're ripping
people off most people grow up in one of
those two camps that's the lesson that's
been taught you by your parents the
truth is money is just a tool money is
an amazing tool that lets you accomplish
amazing things and if you are an
entrepreneur and want to have success
making money has to be in your top five
list of priorities if it is not in your
top five then you're not making money
but it can't be number one money can't
be your number one priority there has to
be something that is more important than
it and that's your purpose i don't
really usually talk a lot about money on
my videos um
maybe i should maybe i should talk more
about it i think it's important i think
there's just so much out there that
seems to be money money money money that
i'm trying to go against it to say like
purpose is number one you have you're
built to serve if you're just chasing
money you're never gonna win i think i
see too many entrepreneurs just chasing
money and so a lot of the content that i
make is more purpose-driven but there's
still
there's still i think a lot of people
who are purpose-driven who've started
the business for the right reasons and
they don't know how to make money and so
maybe i need to switch up some of the
content that i make as well to help
change the perspective around money my
personal view is i hate spending money
until i'm making money
i love making money it's not number one
right serving believing entrepreneurs is
number one
but again it's in the top five because
if i didn't make money i wouldn't have a
team i wouldn't have people to help me
make this video it'd be me by myself
trying to put together one piece of
content you know a week or maybe a day
just you know filming by myself but
instead i have this team of people who
i'm super appreciative of and i can
afford that because i'm making money
doing the business that i'm doing right
kind of important when i look at jeremy
who
i invested into earlier this year this
is this is a great example of how i like
to think right so jeremy runs a youtube
consulting business i invested into him
i had this dream in the desert i'm
driving through the desert on my tour
in march
ish
february around there this year 2019
and i have this idea that jeremy i want
to start a youtube consulting business
with jeremy at the time jeremy was
working at a grocery store stocking
shelves and checking people out
he asked me a bunch of times whether he
could
help me in any way if he could walk my
dog or buy groceries or like anything
just to just to help and i'm like i
don't need to i don't need somebody to
wash my car or walk my dogs and so
you know i said no but i love his hustle
and energy and drive and just
personality and i thought he'd make a
great entrepreneur he's capable of so
much more than just working on a grocery
store
and so i had this dream in the desert
for some reason well not a dream i was
driving so i was fully awake i told nina
we need to get jeremy on the line right
now
uh i had this idea so she messaged him
on facebook and i said i need to talk to
him right now and uh at first he wasn't
available i said like you gotta get him
on the on the facebook live right now
like i need to talk to him on the video
right now
because if i waited till tomorrow i
would have i would have pushed it off
right i got an inspired idea let's go
and i said here's this idea i've got i
wanna teach you youtube i wanna uh i
wanna have you
learn everything that i know about it
and i wanna start a youtube consulting
business with you
and here's what you need to do are you
in and he said yeah i'm in i want to do
it he didn't really know a ton about
youtube at that point in time besides
coming to my thought leadership academy
the the
i guess the couple months before i said
okay before i come back i'm going to be
home in two months here's what you need
to learn you need to watch all of these
videos where i talked about youtube you
need to watch these other channels that
talk about youtube you need to analyze
data you need to come up with
suggestions and feedback and you need to
know what you're when i come home i was
90 days on the road when i come home you
have to learn and know and understand it
you got to be an expert
and he's great at learning so i thought
he would crush it where i thought he
might struggle is on the interaction and
talking to clients because he hadn't
done that work before so when i got home
the first step was
you're gonna you're gonna hop on a free
call you're gonna get some free advice
to people who've come to the thought
leadership academy and do youtube audits
on them
uh tell them you're gonna record the
call and then i'm gonna listen in with
you afterwards
and he did a great
job it i knew he'd be prepared and have
the research and know what he's doing
because he he studies and he works like
nobody else but i didn't know he'd do so
well and actually being able to handle
the objections and handle the push and
the movement to help them and he's only
gotten better with time too but this is
listen this is since we started the
business together in april
and he's already building a six-figure
business
from a guy who went from stocking
shelves so now we're talking about how
do we scale it up beyond him
he can only max out a certain number of
clients and still
you know serve them properly
uh do we bring on somebody else
underneath him and just keep increasing
the prices what kind of business do you
want to build
six-figure business you know inside of
five months it's crazy right i mean
maybe not so crazy but from an idea to
action but didn't spend any money to
start it there were no ads that were
taken out is just research hard work
hustle outreach
telling people he can help them and it
was him reaching out to people who he
thought could really benefit that he had
knowledge that could help them and
saying i'd love to set up a free call
with you and he set up these half an
hour calls we was walking through and
giving them advice and he had three big
ideas for each client and and most
people wouldn't then hire him like most
people who come on a call you're not
they're not going to hire you right away
um but you hit a certain percentage
right and you get better in targeting
who you're going to go after and reach
and so now we've built a six-figure
business and plus now we're looking at
really scaling up for next year
and so
having this conversation i guess around
money how to build a business quickly
without having to spend money um i think
is important and so maybe i'll try to
include more of that content love to
know your thoughts uh that could be the
question of the day let me know your
thoughts do you want more content about
making money uh on the channel you can
let me know in the comments below but
i'm gonna give you a three-step process
that i think will help you step number
one is don't start spending money until
you're making it don't spend money until
you're making it so easy to spend money
this is the thing when i was in venture
capital raising money for companies
everybody just showed how they're gonna
spend money but not how they're gonna
make it right it's so easy to think
about if i only had ten thousand dollars
fifty thousand dollars a hundred
thousand dollars whatever you can go buy
all this stuff stop thinking about the
money you don't have right instead you
think about what you can do with what
you do have
what can you use you're a genius you're
resourceful you've got ideas how do you
use that creativity instead of thinking
the biggest problem is money the problem
is not money the problem is you're not
resourceful enough go off and solve that
problem right jeremy had a budget of
zero and still has a budget of zero to
build his business
and even if you're doing a product right
say well he's doing a service great
maybe you actually start as a service
maybe your product id you should start
as a service and get close to your
customers and build a reliable
repeatable income stream but if you're
going to do a product you pre-sell
right you pre-sell you you make a
you make a mock-up and if you can't
actually make like a mug to show then
you make a design of it right you do a
mock-up there's always a smaller way to
get started and you pre-sell you're not
putting enough hustle energy heart
dedication into it and you're blaming
lack of money too many people maybe not
you but too many people that's the
problem don't spend money until you're
making money it's a great rule to start
by number two is study wealthy people
who share the same values as you this is
this is where it becomes particularly
difficult because you might look at some
people who have money who've made it and
say well that person is such a whatever
right that person is is evil or that
person is whatever you come up with a
story in your mind and so
even if you're looking at youtube
whether you're looking at my content or
gary or grant or tom or patrick or any
of the mel any of the people creating
content
think about first who do you resonate
with
on values
right maybe you love gary and hate grant
or maybe you love grant and you hate
gary maybe you love dan and hate evan
right great
awesome
go learn from that person go learn from
that person because the way that they
think about money could be the thing
that you need the most and so surround
yourself with them watch their videos
read their books go to their events to
see that somebody who has the same
values as you
can make money so that's possible so
don't so that you don't feel like i'm a
nice guy or a nice girl and i can never
make money because i want to rip people
off there's lots of people who are
making lots of money and not ripping
people off so find your favorites and
model them and be around them and
surround yourself with them if if only
virtually like even if you never meet
them if only virtually so that their way
of thinking their thought process and
money starts to seep into you and step
number three is understand that money
lets you serve the more money you have
the more you can serve right what
happens if you're not making money then
this thing that you love doing this is
what this part the last section built
the server if you guys don't have built
a server you can pre-order in the link
below the last section i built to serve
the whole the first part is all about
finding your purpose right you were
built to serve how are you built to
serve the process is in here right
the last section though is how to turn
it into a business because if you found
your call and if you found the thing
that is your purpose that you want to do
for the rest of your life but you can't
turn it into something that's going to
pay you
the problem is you're just doing it as a
hobby for the rest of your life and and
there's nothing necessarily wrong with
that you're still helping you're still
giving you're still contributing but you
can only do it on the evenings and
weekends because you're not making
enough money to actually support
yourself so you have to have this job
that you know maybe you hate maybe you
don't hate but isn't actually your thing
and then when you get home the last
couple hours of the weekends those hours
you can use to fulfill your purpose and
that's great and that's noble but what
if you could turn your full-time thing
into the thing that fulfills your
purpose so that one you're happier
because you're doing more work on the
thing that you love doing right but then
two you can scale it up
you can hire people now and now instead
of just you part-time fulfilling your
purpose you have yourself and a whole
team of people of 10 100 1 000 people
all contributing towards your mission
which then allows you to give
right at every event that i do there's
always
usually aim for 10
um of people who were in for free who
couldn't afford it
right so on my tour when we go on the
workshop on the tour um we're doing 20
something cities over almost 90 days
10 of the room will be free
because they can't afford it because
maybe they're homeless
you wouldn't know it there's a lot of
people who are homeless that you would
not know are homeless right
uh whenever i do my thought leadership
academy in toronto it's a it's a i don't
know i forget where the ticket is a
couple thousand to come
there's always somebody in the room
who's there on basically a sponsorship
right it's a it's a
i wanna say donation it's uh what when
you give to education i don't know
anyway
we let somebody in for free
somebody who can't afford it somebody
who i believe and who i think has a
message and and will take a lot from
this training
and they get in for free and because i'm
making money that allows me to do that
if if i wasn't getting paid at all from
any of the people who come out then i
couldn't just do it all for free every
time because then i can't afford a
location i can't afford to have my team
members i couldn't be able to put it
together so understanding making that
shift in your head that money allows you
to serve the more money you make the
more you can serve the more you can help
people and if you actually want to
fulfill your purpose then you have to
learn how to make money in your business
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below
on this video i will showcase you and
celebrate you somewhere on the screen in
a future video because you are awesome
if you want to learn what to do with
your money to build your wealth check
the video right there next to me i think
you'll love it continue to believe and
i'll see you there we grow up with these
things i call invisible scripts and
these are the scripts that are beliefs
that are so powerful
we don't even realize that they're
they're around us that's why they're
invisible so a classic one in america